so I guess it's like this it's an
observation of mine in the 90s we made
movies about trying to get an orca out
of captivity in this decade we make
movies about a group of people who are
hoping that Dolphin goes into captivity
so winter can have a roommate I don't
know just weird to me the times they are
a-changin
[Music]
Dolphin Tale - to Dolphin Tale 2 is the
sequel to Dolphin Tale remember in
Dolphin Tale was almost called him
snowflake wrong movie same seasons his
name's winter winter was a dolphin he
had no tail then they had to construct a
tail for him a prosthetic tail by Lucius
Fox in this movie winter is a little
busy because winters roommate dies and
now they need to find winter a new
roommate which is pretty much the gist
of the movie as it should be what else
this movie has a whole story arc about
the Maine kid in this movie he's going
out he's getting like a full ride
scholarship to college and maybe he
needs to go on that maybe he wants to
stick around here there's this girl
maybe who's interested in him and maybe
he's interested in her and this other
girl who maybe he's friendzone didn't
know friends and that's a word I think
ultimately they're all way too young to
be thinking about this [ __ ] right now
get down with your academics then you
can think about dating basically I'm not
comparing this movie to Transformers I'm
really not but it does suffer from the
same problem a transformer suffers from
verses too many human beings we want
what we came for which is dolphins yeah
granted you need the humans to have a
story for sure and the main kid in this
one he was the main kid in the last one
you know he's bonded with winter not
snowflake I almost called winter
snowflake here but when that starts
eclipsing the entire dolphin story it is
called Dolphin Tale you got to step back
and go guy come on if there's something
that can be left on the cutting room
floor a lot of that stuff is it this
movie does have its share of heartfelt
moments some of them did cheesy for sure
just like the first movie was cheesy in
that hallmark movie kind of way same
thing here hey they know what works for
it got him a sequel however I love the
end credits in these Dolphin Tale movies
the first one I was like alright it's
based on a true story in the end credits
you see the real footage you're like oh
that's mind-blowing and this one I was
like yeah but is it still based on true
stories it's a sequel that's also based
on a true story or is it springboarding
off of the true story now they're
starting to make [ __ ] up know if you see
real footage in the end credits of this
one - I was like wow they can just keep
going as long as really heartfelt
moments keep happening in real life they
can make dolphin tell movies around that
this place man is like a beacon for
heartfelt [ __ ] for oh that's nice
however I don't think the movie was
pitched right via the poster that right
there that's like the last half an hour
of the movie I mean look at that you
think the movies about winter bonding
with this other little dolphin named
hope it's not it's about winter having a
severe psychological breakdown and
everyone else around winter having a
breakdown also like
maybe maybe we'll just lose winter the
losing winter maybe they should have
called this movie summer is coming
written by george RR martin everyone
dies so in the end winter's tale is a
feel-good movie you can take your kids
to see it doesn't feel like a hallmark
movie at times is it cheesy at times is
it concentrate on the humans that you
don't care about as much as the dolphins
yeah but it's still a good movie to take
your family to if you're like alright
we've been sci fi duppy neveri 1 kill
each other in the galaxy a hundred times
over and people have traveled through
time and Captain America is still
awesome we got that blu-ray we've
watched it seven times what to do now
let's tone it down alright Dolphin Tale
- so in the end I will say Dolphin Tale
- is a good time no alcohol required
their families are you personally gonna
put down your destiny game to go watch
this movie no you're not no more than
you put down Gears of War to watch
Dolphin Tale 1 this is the world we live
in right so what's your favorite
heartfelt movie of all time
smart ass is out there I know you're out
there like mm what a Space Odyssey I
know you think cuz it's kind of stupid
[ __ ] I would say it's a respect for that
no real heartfelt movie whatever it is
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you wanna see more click right here to
see more
[Music]